it is now time for me even welcome to
the world armwrestling league
[Music]
[Applause]
this is epic this is history
[Applause]
from a place known as the Steel City
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
live from stage a any some competitors
with arms of steel and iron wills ready
to go the world armwrestling league 501
with some heavy heavy hitters leaning
off tonight
crowded side stage AE is ready to go so
are we
[Applause]
as we will chase it up here alongside
max Tobin we got seemingly everything
tonight we got up-and-comers established
stars stars that have been away from the
sport that are coming back and we got a
hammer championship here on the line I
know you've been waiting for this since
the end of last season Jason there's
probably no one here more excited me to
see these matchups we got so much
excitement tonight inch too hard to put
into words so imma let the action talk
for me yeah the crowd is ready to go we
got five premiere matches for you
tonight as we look at our match car here
from Pittsburgh
Tony Kitts housekey iron arm against
Doug Ehrlich the animal Jordan sill
storm Ciolino the Pennsylvania product
ready to go into his home state the
women take the third match Victoria
Carlson from Sweden against Nancy Locke
ending a long layoff coming back to the
spore then for the middleweight title
our BJ ready to go Rob pigeon jr.
against Craig - yay and we end it with a
super heavyweight showdown
Devin Lehren Todd Hutchings no limits
against Todd Zilla but there's so many
to talk about picks up yeah of course
the marquee matchup as the final match
Devin No Limits
first Todd Silla they've never pulled
they're two of the best for their weight
of all time and it's gonna be really
exciting to see who comes out on top but
every match tonight should be incredibly
exciting to see
we got some experienced performers here
again the women with Carlson from sweet
Nancy ma coming back after a 25-year
layoff from the sport excited to see
what they have to offer - and we'll
begin with some emotion and certainly
some power in our first showdown of the
night Gutowski and Erlich go toe to toe
and we expect to see some fireworks
again from this pair and you look at
Tony Kotowski at one point certainly the
best in his weight has moved up now is
coming back down to take on Orlick and
there's not allowed to known about
Erlich right now at least in the world
arm world armwrestling league it's gonna
be a very exciting first matchup because
these guys are really really wanting to
test the limits of who's the best in the
lightweight category we can't wait to
talk about that but first we need to set
the stage with the rules of the game
here in the world armwrestling league
the referee begins the match by
centering the competitors hands on the
table
hands must be leveled closed and tightly
set if their grip slips they will be
placed in the strap during the match the
arm wrestlers must be their noble on the
pad at all times
win the match of competitor must touches
opponents hand or wrist to the path or
break the plane of the pin line three
fouls is a loss so there's what you need
to know as we get set for our first best
of five crowd here in Pittsburgh they're
certainly passionate about their sports
and here's the tale of the tape for the
well the clear thing you're gonna see
here is Doug's record and the doubles
you know it is zero because he's his
first match to the Super Series Toni's
the veteran Doug's got hungry underdog
and it's gonna be interesting matchup
here well certainly the Taos key again
we talked about it certainly at his
weight top moved up and now he's come
back down but certainly wants to prove
something but again Berlocq the animal a
little bit different animal because he
hasn't seen a lot of tape doesn't know
what to expect from they got different
motivations Tony returning to the
mountain top of where he's been the
champ and Doug just trying to climb to
it it's the new hungry guy trying to
chase that title best like baby again
Ironman up at middleweight coming back
to light way we'll see what he has to
showcase tonight him from Junction City
Wisconsin population 406 he says well
the other 405 gonna be rooting hard for
their guy
tonight the season Pittsburgh ready to
go against Doug Erlich and for Erlich
coming up certainly we understand he'll
be going on against Gutowski we
mentioned Tony Kotowski away from the
table let's meet him at home in
Wisconsin I am Tony katulski I pull the
165 pound weight class I belong to
Rudolph Fire Department for me to be a
part of something that can actually help
people is something I've always wanted
to do the rewarding side of it if you
can save somebody else's life as makes
it worthwhile I'm just a volunteer EMS
and the firefighters are the full-time
guys they see this stuff every single
day I have all the respect in the world
for them sell beverages be able to get
out and talk to different people it
couldn't get any better than that
Randy our top seller is actually
chocolate my favorite is vanilla fourth
of July parade this year we got to
represent their church I'll be walking
alongside the truck to make sure nobody
runs in front of it that was exciting
but now we go home a train training
first let's do a grip work off this what
I call the grip of death works
everything simultaneously like to grab
onto this thumbs honor don't close with
my thumb just close with my fingers
wrists are in I don't put any pressure
on my thumb they used strictly finger
strength during it I've trained
exceptionally hard to get to where I am
dedication is key after placing last
year seventh place right hand and not
placing left I vowed this year to come
back and do something far better
inside the life of Toni Pitt's house you
don't forget you can catch all the world
armwrestling league action on VR live
download the VR live app on your mobile
device TV Roku and Amazon fire TV now
let's check in with our Pitt public
address announcer
Ian Rick Abani our opening contest is a
best-of-five lightweight bull our first
puller is a 5 foot 8 electrician with a
professional record of 27 and 9 he was
the 2016 double hammer champion
competing out of Junction City Wisconsin
he weighs in tonight at 169 pounds he is
Tony
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and introducing his opponent he is
making his wal debut he is a winner of
15 state and six national titles this
six foot civil engineer is weighing in
tonight
also at 169 pounds he's competing out of
Destin Florida he is Doug
[Music]
oh yeah dr. Eddie certainly is guys look
ready he's coming hungry he's down your
dog this match and he's got a lot to
prove and he's got a lot of motivation
to do so enter the area down some cold
hard cash as we are ready to go all
right head referee okay gentlemen to the
table
watch here again first here in the
best-of-five can I ask you before we do
anything square your shoulders open your
hands flat good right in the middle
lemon looks good I want a clean fair
start listen to all my commands do not
move unless I tell you
close your thumbs stay right here do not
up in stay right here accompany his
right hand he's using cotton to steal
elevator doors there are some scars you
can see right on the knuckles still
smaller than the fingers a little bit
said he couldn't move them for a while
almost had a scan extension maybe for
this match tonight but it is ready but
he hasn't dream no it's hard to say but
it's certainly not gonna make things any
easier and this first match I say a lot
let's see what happens right here
they're strapped today right here where
has everything ready to see who gets the
political position here
he's waiting he knows his position his
superior
I was waiting
he knows he's in control in there
[Applause]
this is a very unexpected story at least
in my point of view let's take a look at
the replay here and see exactly what
happened look it's house key able to as
you say get position just by this time
and he took his hand and just improved
position improved leverage and he knew
he was in the position to pin him and
just waited for the right time to do it
iron arm celebrating the first and
asswad of respect for Erlich as he gets
the first in this best-of-five so now
92nd clock between poles we're getting
to the halfway point try to those arms
down I think I just heard from Doug's
corner that he said he felt a pop
something pop three times it's like bad
it's already slow
no there was no something happened
something happened no I mean it's like a
shooting bang I can't use my phone
something happened here dogs dig deep
here you heard him talking about his
elbow a lot of pain take a look at the
replay that that's a tough position on
our yeah
[Music]
so Erlich the animal try to step up here
for Destin Florida we knew she was
number one that's why I want him slip
there and we're gonna go to the strap
again this Erlich is certainly yeah
that's where the tendon attaches Jason
and it's a calm and injuring arm recipe
especially if you feel a pop on that
tendon oh it's one of the most painful
things and your arms are starting to
swell up immediately
yeah Doug unwilling to give up asked him
and he clearly said no way these guys
have warrior mentality
[Applause]
dog was trying to protect
and you feel him and see that look of
pain as it goes again to the favor of
Kotowski yeah Tony's in control right
now and it's tough you know
Doug's clearly injured something it's
hard to say the exact type of injury but
it's bad you've been in that position
use your back and your arm more weight
towards you put some space in your labs
and low it my elbow can't support my
side pressure at all I don't need too
long he's got the permanent damage might
be he's got at the break the filter
there popular times there's something
really not this is B that's no side role
like you're not giving him advice in the
real space in your lap the second round
you know Doug had a little bit of a
better position but clearly you see the
elbow just can't support the pressure
right now you got better back and laugh
at him take your head high and roll just
broke don't even worry about the elbow
side don't panic grow and let him let
him take the advice from our VJ is to
take the pressure away from his elbow
try to try to pull back and just negate
as much pressure on the injury spot as
he can which is the right advice
everything yeah everything was planned
perfect everything perfect easier said
than done any money easy money we'll see
them later in a highly anticipated show
boys way to let him crack up like this
keep working it back believe me I did
our years of winning on the bicep you
can do it with your rotation you are
BJ's advice stay away from the injury
use your bicep grow him just anything to
get away from all the pressure being on
that spot in the elbow easier said when
it's not your arm that's screaming at
this point on that that's right
we'll see what erlik's got it it's three
in a row to stay alive he takes his hand
again
[Applause]
and Tony matowski it through tell girl
again clearly fighting an issue that
fits house key on this one
taking control at the outset and takes
away
- - iron arm with the wind and he's back
we're gonna take a replay here of the
last round
Tony lifting control right from the
start and doctors can't use his power he
can't get into a good position his arms
open and Tony just exposes that and
finishes it get a guy who won 2016 wal
lightweight tie those left and right
arms and moved up the middle weights
back at home at lightweight and look at
strong and Tony is with our interviewer
jason fisher tony Kotowski
congratulations you start our season off
here wal with a big win now after a year
of pulling at middleweight you're back
to lightweight how does this weight
class suit you if this weight class
feels a whole lot better I'm not pulling
six foot four guys anymore when you're
five foot seven two foot shorter than
damn it hurts well you looked like
you're you're not even that tired you
could go again yeah let's do it alright
so what's next for you what's next for
Tony Kotowski this year let me tell you
what's next the gentleman in this crowd
Sam Harris I want your ass
[Applause]
there is who is up next perhaps we'll
see all right Jason max this is a great
start here so far congratulations
certainly is so we'll see if the wal has
taken requests here Tony
well it's Sam Harris coming up next as
he took down Doug Erlich here in three
straight again clearly something going
on with Doug but Tony taking advantage
and right here it looks like he knows
he's got his man yeah he was in control
from the first round and it just
superior hand strength from Tony I mean
give Doug credit he he had an injury he
kept fighting through it you know it's
so tough when something just goes and
you can't use your arm the right way
anymore but you know credit to Tony he
just came strong and prepared certainly
that's the case and Kotowski with that
winning formula and able to celebrate
that final pin to close it out in three
straight well we are getting ready for
some of our biggest matches of the night
we can't wait for what's coming a little
bit later on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the world armwrestling league
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this place hosted some concerts these
fans are rocking here the stars of Wal
learn a little lingo about the world
armwrestling Lee hello everyone my name
is Mike Fontenot with the world almost
week and we're gonna talk to you today
about to start we have a two phase start
with the WL our opponents gonna walk up
to the table they're gonna have 30
seconds okay that I'm gonna assist them
in getting a grip and negotiating a fair
start okay we're gonna come up palm to
palm thumbs up I'm gonna struck you to
close your thumbs
straighten your wrists close your hands
go if they fail to negotiate a grip and
there's too much going on we're gonna go
into Phase two and introduce the straps
once the straps have been applied we're
gonna close your thumbs straight and
wrists closed hands go and that's our
cadence we use at the W so that gives
you a sense of what we're talking about
here we're talking to world armwrestling
league as we get ready for our next
match up storm ciolino and Jordans sill
on the way two guys that had matches not
go their way towards the tail end of
last year but they certainly have the
skill sets to WoW and amaze they're
similar in strength similar in size I
think this is going to be a very even
matchup you take us to the tail of the
tape for Jordan the thrill sill from
Layton Utah
storm ciolino a home state product from
Scott Township PA over by strand
northeastern portion of the state you
look at their size roughly the same
Toledo at six foot six to four sill and
you look at this guy outside of Scranton
PA what does he do well he's a hand
control specialist look at the position
that he wants to get in is his hand to
be dominant and he wants to finish
through that hand strength and hand
control Jorn seldom a little bit more
versatile and he could go in a lot of
other places and certainly we've got a
lot of guys that have big muscles but
for his size Jordans he'll certainly is
well put together you look at ciolino
able to finish strong with that speed
and power combination and here's a look
at the man from just north of Salt Lake
City in Utah
yes el East East he's a big guy he's
gotten to horsepower but he's got angles
he's got technique as well so he's a
well-rounded
a lot of experience and he actually has
the winning record first storm he told
me he's got about 10 wins on storm storm
only has one on him that's a lopsided
rivalry it is but as he said it was the
last one and it was right-handed for
guys that have gone back and yeah with
both arms so arms got the latest wind so
who's more confident it's hard to say I
think this one's gonna be a coin flip
absolutely and we're gonna find out
who's going to get the next win coming
up in just a bit but here's what storm
Ciolino had to say a bit earlier today
so going against Jordan still he's a
much bigger arm wrestler power polar I'm
gonna use my hand control and my hand
strength and my speed to dictate where
this match goes and dominate the match
now if it gets into his power and he
gets a good you know set up then it
might be debatable but I don't plan on
letting it get there so the thoughts
there from storm ciolino look at the wal
fan who they think is gonna win pretty
close storms got 52 percent to 48
percent for Jordan sale and if I was a
betting man in oddsmaker these are the
exact odds I would give this match coin
flip let's get ready for our
introductions let's get you back to our
pit announcer Erica Boni the following
contest is a middleweight bout scheduled
best out of five polls introducing first
from nearby Scott Township Pennsylvania
he won the 2015 left-handed middleweight
championship since his teenage years he
has dominated armwrestling and enters
tonight with an impressive 30 and eight
professional record standing at 6 feet
tall weighing at 210 pounds he is storm
Charlie
[Applause]
and introducing his opponent pulling out
of Layton Utah this father of four is a
restaurant manager who finds himself
using in his own words whatever it takes
to win standing 6 feet 1 inches tall
weighing in tonight at 210 pounds
introducing Jordan the thrill sir
so the competitors rolling out we
mentioned both these guys coming off
losses both of them lost to our VJ Rob
pigeon jr. towards the tail end of last
year's SIL talked about hey I was
injured but no excuses I got beat torn
tendons backside of the res he's all
healed up and Ciolino talked about
changing his strategy to get ready for
this the training as you see the money's
been laid on the table now the wal money
girl as we get ready to go yes dogs are
training more variation they feel better
than he's ever felt and I know how feels
good as well let's listen to Bart here
with the club no side pressure flat
gotta go Jorge's ways Jordans way that
means this one right there more more
right there close your thumb stays
straight note I can't have any end
that's straight do not cover the thumb
knuckle no pressure
close your hands go
[Applause]
Thunder is decided with the grip
sometimes yeah with the position look at
the positioning you can see he took his
he took his hand on top of Jordans
isolate his wrist and opened him up
using pressure from the top we truly
know talked about keeping him in the
words of truly know Jordan sill I'm
coming for the scalars here did that end
it quick he trains around you know the
state very well-known puller around here
Sam Harris wal lightweight hammer older
in his for over 90 seconds rolling
between these down to the final 30
Toledo it pumped up again here Sam
Harris right behind them and they're
very good friends former training
partners for a long time I know they
trained together and still do and we
know he's here Tony kids house key
already called them out after winning
our first match of the night and they
might set that one up for later tonight
those guys are ready to go wears each
other 30 seconds to give you 20 seconds
on the clock let's listen in yeah it
can't be 10:00 to 2:00 gotta be 12 good
your way a little bit Jordan right
there's good close your thumbs stay
right here don't with no rising pressure
nothing close your hands go
[Applause]
that is the press
back-to-back quick pins from storm
Selena wins he said out of rvj back to
the eighth he wants him let's take a
look at the replay just technical and
hand strength that's what I'm seeing
from storm positioning and just going
through his hand power to finish the
match
Jorn can't get anything he wants they
say his hand and wrist are top-notch and
we have seen it right now as he's top
Jordans sill twice in a row to put him
on the precipice of going out threes hip
and storm so confident right now really
dig deep and come up with a different
game plan because storms dominating them
right now in the hand and wrist alright
if you're Jordan sill what is that
different game plan now the killer what
Chile knows coming at you it needs
distraction he needs to get in the strap
and be able to put his full power down
because right now outside the trap he
can't do it in storms taking advantage
of his hand every time
julinho again used to fib about his age
he says when he was a kid he was 16 even
when he was 13 so he could complete
wrestling divisions had success
become a star here in armwrestling
league yes the one started competing at
13 he's 27 now so even at 27 years old
he's basically a veteran with 1415 years
experience carries to see where Jordan
is here to make an adjustment close your
thumbs stay right here close your hand
[Applause]
anywhere Cellino wraps up yeah our
second sweep of the night in the hand
wrist combination too much force oh yeah
let's take a look at the replay here I
mean it was evident the second Bart said
go look at storms hand positioning
Jordan couldn't go anywhere he couldn't
put his power down he couldn't get
position let's take another look right
here all into Jordan's fingers you see
the pressure there Jason yeah Jordan
can't put it down and Jordans Hill knows
that Ciolino was the better guy tonight
and the winter storm standing by with
Jason Fisher storm Ciolino you're a
pretty mild mannered a guy but when you
get in this ring you turn into a totally
different person where does that come
from
well if you have to have different
mindsets so when you're you know out
here you just bring out the best most I
don't even know how to describe but just
like animal in you just to you know be a
beast on the table and got to give it a
hundred and thirty percent of your
energy well everything on the table the
animal definitely came out and you
definitely did leave everything out here
on the table you made pretty quick work
of Jordan sill and I see you saying to
the camera you want the hammer
you want the hammer who do you want next
whoever's got the hammer
obviously rvj kind of put a little
damper in my goal last year so there's
still some history there but we'll see
whoever has the hammer that's why I got
to go for even if you know whatever
taste is last year I started off good
you know fell short of my goal and I
tweaked my training completely and my
diet changed I have to give a huge
thanks to my girlfriend she's been
making me six meals a day I have new
training partners that I've been pulling
on my arm two three times a week
hitting the gym twice a day I just had
to give it more effort that's amazing
six meals a day at least well it's
working is this your girlfriend right
here sure what's her name Tara Tara
alright Tara is there anything you want
to say to taro to thank her for getting
you ready for this competition right
here I have to thank her because he's
going against Jordan still he's a much
bigger opponent than I am and I had to
gain some weight to get up to his level
because he's just an overall bigger
human being them I walk around a little
lighter than him amazing well storm you
are a beast on the table and back to a
mild-mannered gentleman after a amazing
job
congratulations can't wait to see what's
next for you max and Jay so you're not
taking me down all right back to you
guys Jason thanks storm Ciolino is a
power plant technician at home works at
one in Jessup Pennsylvania there's power
in the arms as well he's he's the winner
of our second bout and right now max is
standing by with a winner of one of our
prelim bouts tonight Brandon L sesor to
explain at the demo table how we got the
victory so let me just tell you guys
when storm was able to pull back into
his hand and secure hand control this is
the position that one of them to match
from here Jordan just couldn't get any
of us power over he couldn't do anything
storms and control and he was able to
just dictate the match from there and
pin him with the top roll finish
textbook stuff from Storm Julie no max
Brandon thanks for the demonstration as
the guy from Pennsylvania wins in his
home state his 31st victory against 8
losses more action to come here as you
look again in the victory from Storm
ciolino he knew it was coming and he
gets it done in three meet time we got a
hammer on the line tonight championship
out rvj against two yay
hey dual for the wao middleweight hammer
coming up a little later
craziest thing I've ever seen in a match
um I've seen a lot of trace of things
broken arms arm breakings multiple
number of broken arms I've witnessed an
arm break before just hearing that snout
it wasn't nice
besides the broken arms um explode like
with blood guys having so much
adrenaline the guy's just going so hard
as he can hey just pass out boom dude
hit the ground he just passed out mat
mask broke his finger like yanked it
just went right back into it that
7-minute Gerry cataract match Jericho to
resin Michael Todd I'll be biased
it was crazy insane I don't think I've
ever seen one that long before there's
so much coming down for my face and it's
going to my eyes so I'm trying to think
you know they don't want to lose for
nothing seven minutes to get a restart
and press the hell out of me that's in
sane but it got me here you never know
what you're gonna see at the table
that's why we watch here in Pittsburgh
steel city city of bridges 446 of them
and we're gonna bridge the gap to our
featured match coming later tonight
Jason Fisher standing by with Rob
fidgets Judy our Vijay you're the
defending middleweight wal champion is
there a difference between coming up
going for that hammer versus defending
the crown absolutely I think coming up
it's easy there's not as much pressure
on you you know you can just kind of be
that guy that's climbing the ranks but
once you get on top there's a lot of
expectations and pressure from the
outside and pressure from yourself to
stay there you want to validate that you
didn't just luck your way in depending
on who they threw at you you want to
show that you got the spot of the best
and you maintain the best well you got
the hammer now but immediately you're
being tested someone is coming for it
what do you think of your chances
tonight in this match he's a very
dangerous opponent and he stylistically
for me is very he makes me very uneasy
when I think I'm coming in prepared for
him enough that
I think I've got a really good shot all
right well good luck we can't wait to
see guys back to you Jason Rob thanks
we'll see how Craig - yay tell us and
that matchup against our Vijay a little
bit later as we get down to our third
match of the night Victoria Carlson from
Sweden matched up against Nancy Locke
who was a store in the 80s and 90s
walked away but she's walked back in the
door here max it's such an interesting
back story Nancy Locke competed in the
80s and 90s retired after she apparently
broke her ribs in 1993 has not competed
since 25 year layoff but now she's
coming back let let let's take a look at
the tale here and certainly we see these
two in Victoria Carlson from Sweden came
over and made her first ever trip to the
states for match up in Atlanta didn't go
her way but certainly she's shown signs
of being a high level performer here
she's made the trek all the way back to
see if she can get a better result
tonight yeah she got the exposure and
now I think she's gonna come in a lot
more ready for the wal the rules the
venue the table everything I think
she'll be prepared and I'm interested to
see what Nancy brings to the table so
we're looking here at Carlson and Locke
coming up
Sweden against Canada although Locke now
calls California home but again Canadian
native really plying her trade there
before making the move to California in
the last couple of years let's look at
some of the particulars here with the
ratings of these two performers max yeah
you know it's tough to differentiate
them here they're pretty even a lot of
these stats I think the tables gonna
tell you a really direct message of
who's the stronger and better puller and
we'll see how the format works for them
as well again best-of-five something
certainly gonna be new for Nancy lot
will catch all the world armwrestling
league action on be our live download
the be our live app on your mobile
device Apple TV Roku and Amazon fire TV
but we're ready for the introductions
here let's get you back to Ian
Rick Ambani the fall
contest is a women's match with
international implications introducing
first throughout the 80s and 90s this
competitor went undefeated in the
lightweight division after 25 years she
returns to pulling and makes her w al
debut from Ottawa Canada now residing in
California weighing in tonight at 128
pounds please welcome the legendary
Nancy certainly is her opponent is one
of the sweetest scenes young guns
standing in at five feet two inches tall
this puller dedicated her life to
armwrestling and is making her return to
wal give it up for Victoria Carlson
[Music]
here's carlson and again for those maybe
North America that don't know Sweden is
stacked you know if you want to talk
world level female armwrestling no
country produces more than Sweden and
she's one of the better the best you
know of the nation and ready to pretty
wao money girl bringing the cash right
to the table uses to win get ready to go
it's a new school verse old school match
up Jason
new blood Toria Carlson once everybody
set we've got arrived she said don't be
surprised if I lose my first poll said
it almost always happens to me but then
my mind gets ready to go with Nancy
Locke is ready for business
yeah I get the intensity voluntarily
make no mistake Jason these girls get in
town
watch this one foul right here a a
little bit of our early pull there on
Victoria one foul straight right here
close your thumbs right eye
I'll do the job you can stay right here
vote the straight palm to palm ladies
both lat
close your head time go into the strap
they couldn't get a clean grip we're
going to the strap so right away to the
strap in that first foul in Carlson
three and you lose that round so Locke
gets to the strap here early off
Nancy Locke stepped away from the score
ninety-three out of it from divorced
said she missed the competition wanted
to get back in him find some training he
California won a couple of tournaments
then called up would armwrestling league
and said hey do you remember me and the
league said she's ready to go let's say
right here right
[Applause]
deep inside we're looking to make an
adjustment dead center of the table
right now Jason dead center even right
now member Carlson says first one isn't
usually her thing but then the brain
gets going the brain got going about
half way here as she's locked in here if
she loses the rounds goes to Victoria
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
knew that she let it go and didn't want
to compromise her arm in the bad
position
so I'm Eric waterful from California Joe
and Nancy used to know him on the old
circuit they reconnected eventually
they've gotten married and together now
living in California and training but
again this scene by the Victorian thing
they were let along with it a bit Newton
ants right there but she looks like she
hasn't missed a boozer thumbs
[Applause]
looks like lift it up lift it up at the
front of the pad Jason or wood on top of
it we'll see if Locke can refocus not a
lot of change of expression
[Applause]
her angler win Nancy's in it she gonna
make this easy
[Applause]
alright see me to beg Channel
remember this is round one of the best
of both yeah
and finishes strong sapporo s'en who
says I'm in round one guess what it's in
her favour she was patient she knew
where she had to be and Nancy may be a
little more nervous little jittery to
get and he can't essentially walk one
but neither of them counted with the
running with the running fouls and then
look at the replay here Victoria comes
rotates puts the pressure into the
fingers of Nancy and is able to finish
with a sideways move through the fingers
so it's gotta be stretched getting ready
to battle back here she does dip she's a
character she's interesting and not a
lot of ice in the corner from Eric can
ask Nancy best-of-five format
she said just feels like practice and
essentially that's what she got there
with those two pins that she isn't
finger shooting yeah it's tough but she
committed a foul and a runny foul system
and that's how it goes
she's just got to be a little bit more
patient get to that spot and look to
make a transition and she keep it right
back in this match and take control of
it this is a very even matter Jason were
you just taking rubber straight back
we want to do that okay see what she's
got this time in three World Court of
crowns much Canadian Championships or
stepping away mid-90s she's back here in
2019 making her wao square up please
Karlsson taking round on the ball close
your hands
that counts right back in it she was she
went right to the pack big win and now
she got a big boost of confidence
[Applause]
so now 90 seconds for her to celebrate
and recover and just a flash well no I
would say that was her gaining position
and then accelerating through it she got
the position first then was able to
finish just what she was talking with
with Eric in the corner about doing that
yeah and then he just said Ripper rip
her back into the side and that's
exactly the advice that she took and she
executed so one all here against
Victoria Carlson I have a feeling
endurance is gonna play a part in this
match I think it's gonna be a a long
third round right here and I think it's
gonna really tell where it goes from
here cuz it's really even right now it
could be either of their Majesties
this round will decide who has the
momentum Carlsen trying to loosen up
just your second trip to the United
States asked her how long did it take
her to get here she said well 17 hours
by plane from holding the stock antenna
Frankfort then to DC been here to
Pittsburgh
yeah and you hope you go home with
something to show Rory yeah
have it fun
she said that's part of the things she
missed she missed this she has the
action miss kind of maybe be into the
spotlight a little bit yeah and she's
living up to the hype right now and
loving the spotlight and I think she's
losing the energy of the crowd plus your
thumbs stay right here right here one
foul motion thumb was found Victoria
close your hands go one in one one foul
piece stay right here close your hands
go right back in that book deep inside
who wants this more
look at the foot on the side of the
table by couturier using it to leverage
and push harder to the side that's
you're gonna follow suit yeah she is
they're both in the same position Punk
using the tables leverage pivoting and
just pull it as hard as they can to the
nuts inside finishing both looking for
the pin this is pure horsepower here
Carlson trying to take in and get the
win she's got the position she's in a
little bit better leverage but Nancy's
still in it refused to give it up
looking at her trying to figure a way
out takes the 2-1 lead that was a big
round did it with power deep inside in
the hub was able to get the panel take a
look at this replay Jason similar
position that you've seen him get into
the difference was Victoria is able to
stretch her out separate her from her
own arm and then was able to get that
finish you could see that little nod of
acknowledgment there from Nancy Locke
she knew she was beaten yeah yeah and
now this round is obviously victorious
to either win or Nancy's to make a
heroic come back and force effect so we
had a couple of sweeps to start off the
night for the men and the women
potentially could go the distance here
we'll see if Nancy Locke can send us to
a fifth winner-take-all Pole
if carlson can end it here in fool and
that's the most exciting thing about the
super mad series is when you get that
even matchup and goes to the fifth round
all the chips are on the line it's just
so exciting to see who comes up in that
pressure situation and steps up you
talked about an old-school versus
new-school
trailblazer you heard the advice eric
said keep her away from her body that's
what I was alluding to earlier Victoria
and brought her arm closer her body
giving her a better leverage advantage I
was able to win
[Applause]
here it is
this Victoria gonna seal the deal and
win the match where's Nancy make about
you in Chicago around 4 here we go
they're right here right here close your
hands just lifting at the start just a
little bit before she goes to her moon
and again being able to get there and
finish with those running fouls by my
count that's the fourth one taken away
from her via the running fail that's
training a lot yeah but it's right back
and she's got the cellar position puts
on the power
and we're dead even neither willing to
give it up
we got driver here who watch this more
[Applause]
Taurus and trying to close in on the
waves plows she's back
close but Nancy just won't give it up
she's got a lot of heart right here to
stay in it Vic Sarge no pen no pen yeah
Nancy look at her jaw stand about the
front don't stop another foul that's the
Sun dancing then one more foul and it's
over against Locke come on yeah
three strikes and you're out blows your
phone Nancy's got to be real careful
here mm I'll take it out on the poem
right there you turn his way just a
little bit right there flat right here
palm to palm close your hands go but she
secures a hawk oh it's another great
Brad look at this center of the table
they're waiting each other out who's
gonna make the first mistake
Karlsson again just like the last
matchup here before the foul she's
losing in potentially but Locke will not
relate sir she's an inch from the pin
but Locke won't give it up a lot of hard
to warm the second trip to the states is
sweet Sweden she wanted that bad
celebration for Victoria Carlson take a
look for replay here she surged she had
the slightly better position on the hand
and was she was able to just pull right
over to the side and finish and again
she beats a returning legend of the
sport Nancy Locke here to pick up the
victory 3-1 the final is Jason Fisher is
standing by with our winner Victoria
Carlson Victoria that is a huge win you
just took down an icon in the sport what
does this win mean for you try to put it
in words I lost so it means so much this
is only your second time in the United
States your second wal match the first
was in Atlanta we saw you
how did Atlanta performing under these
bright lights prepare you for tonight
and I want to I want to go here and try
to win this time because I was so
disappointed last time well you did
congratulations you traveled a long way
but the the plane rides home will be a
lot more happy this time around Congrats
we can't wait to see what's next for you
Jason back to you
Jason Victoria thanks as Karlsson
celebrates the victory and again it was
not easy against Nancy Locke who had
some wins herself but a lot being found
yeah but but she did impress me after
such a long layoff to come in and make
it that good of a match versus seasoned
professional and competitor I think that
was a good showing for Nancy and
certainly we expect to see more of
Victoria Carlson and Nancy Locke coming
up here in the world armwrestling league
again big matches still to come
including our middleweight title match
coming up or that hammer this is for the
hammer raw edge and junior defending the
hammer he just won last season first
Craig Tooley a this is going to be an
exciting matchup I know you've been
chomping at the bit we're certainly
ready to bring that one to you here
coming up in just a bit should be a good
one then we'll close the night with no
limits against Todd Zillah super
heavyweight two guys who are as big as
they've ever been what's that gonna mean
for the armor that match is so impressed
grinding endurance type war and I hope
it is I hope I hope it comes up to the
expectations
that's hot Hutchings and Devin lair
coming up to close the night here from
stage AE to end the proceedings on the
night but first it's coming up Craig -
yay chasing a championship he wants what
rvj has the title the hammer the battle
for the middleweight crown it's on the
way from Pittsburgh in just moments
we'll see who takes it out of the bird
here tonight as wal 5:01 continues in
just a moment
the referee begins the match by
centering the competitors hands on the
table the hands must be leveled close
and tightly set if their grip slips they
will be placed in the strap during the
match the arm wrestlers must be there no
mo on the pad and all time to win the
match of competitor must touch his
opponents hand or wrist to the path or
break the plane of the pin line three
fouls is a loss crowd here has been
enjoying a terrific night of world
armwrestling lien year event 501 from
stage AE in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania glad
you're along for the ride here from the
Berk let's take a look back at some of
the action from tonight started Tony
iron on Kotowski Doug Ehrlich Ehrlich
having an issue with the arm and
Kotowski did not let up yeah at the task
you took advantage of that and he came
in strong and ready and was able to
finish that storm Ciolino executed on
his game plan hand control played his
game exactly how he wanted and the match
went his way
dominating with a 3-0 win over torn self
so a couple of three o's sweeps for the
men and then the women extended here
Nancy
she wins but a lot be afoul and Victoria
Carlson able to come back and get it
done
3-1 yeah that was an exciting match very
back and forth both fighting for
position and I turned into a very very
close match so we've got a special guest
here Brandon else Esser won one of the
prelim matches tonight one of the local
world arm wrestling league performers
Congrats on your match tell us a little
bit about what was the reason for
success tonight me and Kevin actually
have a little bit of history I've told a
few times in tournaments over the past
few years and out of all of them he's
probably had the number on me so it
feels really good to get a win over him
today I just knew I had to give it
everything that I could to possibly come
out with a victory and I feel good
here's a look at yourself tonight in
action getting set here on the big stage
here at this big event what was that
feeling like this crowd Wow I couldn't
believe it just felt great everything
worked out perfectly the hook match was
awesome it was good how did the
atmosphere of a big WL super match
series event compared to a local event
like that you won oh it's the local vets
don't contest to the atmosphere around
here I could never get that hyped up
before a match at a local event but here
that's great it's it's unreal good
experience bu the local events kind of
out lifeblood of the sport kind of
building and continuing to grow what's
that camaraderie like for everybody
getting out there and kind of getting
invested in this for everybody that's
into arm wrestling is like one family
but they just love it they trained for
it they do everything that they can to
be the best they can be and everybody
supports each other and it's good
awesome well congratulations on the
victory tonight we look forward to
seeing you here with these big showcases
again someday thank you sir that Brandon
obsessor winning tonight here in our
prelim match to set the scene if you
want to get involved don't forget to go
to the wao website find out where a
local event is coming near your
area we're ready for a hammer on the
line here max tale of the tape between
rbj and the fury I mean the record is
almost exactly the same to the number
there wait almost exactly the same now
rob has the slightly bigger frame the
bigger hand but Craig's coming in the
heaviest of strongest he's ever been
this is a guy that pulled as low as one
in the 1:43 class so Craig's you know
coming in the biggest and best shape and
trying to take the hammer from Rob so
we'll see how these guys perform and
again you talk to both performers as we
did earlier today and 2e8 feels like
he's got a little confidence last
meeting to EA was able to get control
but you look at this guy from his spot
outside Baton Rouge Deneb Springs
Louisiana construction manager for
refinery and boy once he's gotten going
he's moved up he started out as a
bantamweight now who queries that yeah
just went way class by weight class
winning each one on his way up to the
climb to the middle weights and then
he's been you know top to top three in
the wal middle weight class or you know
these last few years just always so
close to that hammer and now he's got a
chance to finally get it now we'll see
if he can get he said I've been chasing
this Amer this is my shot but that guy
has a Rob fijian jr. and he earned it
last year with some critical crucial
wins down the stretch undefeated last
season won every single one of his super
matches and he went the big hammer win
first certain storm ciolino so his
confidence is very high right now he's
riding away from big wins and he's
gotten the biceps show in there
well we said the loss to 2ei but a year
and a half ago really got him back in
heavy training mode and you've seen the
results with him looking nearly flawless
last year and ready to be amped up again
as we look at the ratings for this pair
boy it's tough to figure out who's gonna
take well you know Craig likes to start
off fast and aggressive he's gonna want
to hit hard a lot of speed straight to
the side and he's gonna try to pin raw
early if Rob could stop the match and
use his hamstrings and size to take
control he's gonna have the advantage
well Craig - yeah we talked about him
pride of Louisiana let's visit him on
friendly home turf
i'm craig TVA from Denham Springs
Louisiana I've been on wrestling for 25
years I got 24 national titles and four
world titles Here I am 43 years old and
I'm at the strongest point of my life I
had to move to Lake Charles Louisiana
for a construction job that I'm running
we're building the biggest for fun in
the United States
I'm a construction manager for the
cranes and rigging I've got over 250
guys the hook sites got 3,000 and we're
gonna man up to 10,000 it's a big job
big job they don't describe me at all
adrenaline junkie it's to say the least
this slingshots extreme before I even
picked it up from the dealership we
turbo goes through 200 miles an hour it
is nasty we're good
I had to build a team here in Lake
Charles to pull if there's somebody to
train with good job
we got about 10 guys they get together I
want to see this train hard it's fine
this is what makes us strong over here
in Louisiana the hottest pepper in the
world Carolina Reaper right there come
on this is how we do it down here
[Applause]
everybody says Craig's the legend and
when he walked in the room that people
say hey that's Craig to you that is a
humble champion and that's the way I
want to be
well the humble champ hoping to have a
good time here tonight like he always
seemingly does and hopes that good time
comes in Pittsburgh but a look at our
fan poll they think the good time and
the winds gonna go to our VJ r VJ he's
got the momentum he's the champ
he's the hammer holder and you know that
that's why he's got the higher fan poll
here but this should be an interesting
match let's see what happens well a
hammer hanging in the balance let's get
to our introductions get you back to Ian
Rick about it the following contest is
for the world armwrestling league
middleweight title and the iconic and
prestigious w al hammer introducing
first the Challenger with the stellar 25
and 3 record this star wal
[Music]
[Applause]
this construction manager of the bill is
typically a spiration tonight sitting at
5 feet 10 inches tall weighed 199 pounds
rubbed the handles Louisiana the fury
Craig
[Applause]
Maxie could not wait to get out there
he's ready to go he's focused and he
really wants this and his opponent he is
pulling out of Newburyport Massachusetts
at wal 406 the other father of four
captured his first wal title tonight
weighing in at 203 pounds he enter stage
18 the reigning defending an undisputed
middleweight champion he is there's the
champ looking confident got the hammer
yeah got the hammer and the guns lot
artillery for our Vijay Robinson Jr from
Newburyport Massachusetts about 45 miles
north of Boston and you see the money
girls and the hammer on the line and
what more motivation could you need than
that so we've got the hardware and the
hard cash to the victor in this best oh
that good it's piled up high as these
two guys ready to get after it to the
table gentlemen Bart wood calling them
in not only the money hammers on the
line this is that title match get on
your shoulder set your hands straight
[Music]
this is gonna be fireworks is the start
important since 28 counters the last
time the start is everything in this
match watch this stay right through
these off stay right here they come way
down what is training this one I turn my
gosh
here - nozzle of a knuckle now nor this
trap there's somebody's putting it down
it's a short poem it's not that big I
know your heads up
so again kind of going back forth here
okay
and they're gonna go to the strip right
away and rvj no pressure sometimes you
know over the years says he's 2ei
clearly wanted to try to work him there
yeah this is gonna help play because go
right where you want gonna put the power
down and just put his foot on the gas
and go straight to the side with
everything these guys using the strap
and the start is gonna be critical for
Craig Robert G jr. Johnson to look as
Matt we're losing the users massive hand
right here right here I got you closer
fellas stay right here gentlemen hi I
bought you he's got to come down a
little bit long as I can see right here
I'm good I could I could see were you
gonna go down right there you got to
come down Rob right this your hands now
I'm standing boats are turning in settle
down gentlemen I want a fair start off
setting it right here
the boat's moving hold your tongues
close your head I can see your thumb not
that close your hair where's your hands
one foul not following the commands of
the rep I can see the tongue Rob I can
see the thumb up the thread I see it
close your thumbs close your hands go
that one elbow fountain with the nail mm
chalk up since your elbows down Wow
like I said Frank hit hard
watch your elbow on the hip
[Music]
[Applause]
he hasn't been a bit again in his
position let's look at this replay here
Craig did set the hook but his hand got
compromised and Rob put the pressure and
his fingers opened him back up and was
able to get the pin you see all the
pressures and Craig's fingers right
there isolating that his bicep and
allowing Rob to use his strength and
pull into his fingers to open him up so
Rob pigeon jr. gets the first but I
think Craig is in this Craig can make
this a war and a tough match Rob if he
can get a slightly better hit and have a
better position to start there without
elbow family and that's easier said that
done by Rob yeah I just felt like I
couldn't you so yeah storm Chile you
know great advice the setups are a
[ __ ] nightmare
hey word about that too late talking
about it to see if he can bounce back is
the 90 seconds between poles is just
about done
they'll get called back to the movie I
think neither guys like the center the
both big and each other uncomfortably
trying to get what they want it's going
to be it's going to come right here
Square June you're able to find a way
from flat boom right here close your
thumbs right here's in the center don't
move it we're good right here gentlemen
keep on the ball palm the pump on the
phone that means I'm right here come
around close your hands right here close
your thumbs stay right here just bring
him down close your hands it's a one
foul you're not following the commands
I'm saying close your hands you have to
close I can see it doesn't say I have to
see the whole entire is to get this turn
I want to see flat palm to Palm I can
see thumb not going I want no pressure
I mean for god sake in a perfect world
yeah they get anywhere even stars don't
waste these guys are fighting for every
inch
again those set up inches could mean
everything that could mean the
difference between a win and a loss
especially in this match when they're so
evenly rounded it down come on in the
strap getting set up
Pachulia again started out as a
bantamweight best weight 200 pounds
right here here we go gentlemen
close your thumbs big round stay right
here
do not move close your hands go you got
the pin did get the elbow on hit Ronnie
both on is called by the down what elbow
foul kenwood assisting bar would prefer
jet clean clothes
that's always my confident
[Applause]
rvg to get the win there's a cow yes yes
it does it to us yeah
what we leave it in this minute wait
hold on
[Music]
they're going under corner go to your
corner looks like I'm gonna talk it over
here and make sure they got the recall
right it's what's going on the war but
the officials are going to confirm it a
little bit your system here with an
extra rep there to be able to review in
cases
I very much move into the group because
the guys are like I can't see her submit
she needs to be able to get into this
view a little bit so 2a thinks he's got
it you see if he does can we talked
about him adding weight he says I don't
want to start the weight on I'm forcing
him and I eat about every three hours
says there's days where he has 7080 500
calories intake decide to keep the
weight up to compete at this
middleweight level some man went a
naturally smaller frame that he's just
packed the muscle on every year year
after year and yeah it's not easy to
hold that much on that type of frame
Robert Jr the bigger man the taller man
I'm more of a natural 200-pound guy who
walks around this way year round Craig
Tooley a maybe usually around the 190
range but jumped up since 200-pound
class to be eight to be able to compete
for a middleweight hammer
let's take a look at this replay here
Craig set the hook he got to his power
and look at that surge right there he
used a lat drag to drag an open digit up
and pull him down for the pin let's take
a look at this camera angle you can
really see yeah you can really see the
elbows here Julie a front of the pad
that back of the pad and that's the move
that got him to pin we're still awaiting
the call one one one two one
it is counts to a vision junior film
they've got bonus time to recover here
for both guys Rob said start right here
close that fun stay straight
I can't have this I'm talking closer
here in the hand one five
[Applause]
I'm plenty of a man okay Heather okay
that's easy I am too bro he's moping man
square up we got a little Craig's way
before you anything the pressures
building there's right there close
you're going again
okay right here do not throw it close
your hands Wow there's a strata energy
and intensity building into this matchup
and I love
out of the replay here Craig went to hit
boom Rob took his hand and went over the
top slip Rob newly Adam back to this
trap we go and I've said it before Jason
round three and a one to one it's
pivotal it's so important let's see
who's got it
especially with the history with 2ei
having the better of rvj the last time
they met right here meets me on the
policy you better come around flat oh
yeah this is gonna be fire we're in
center no go Craig zwei drei zwei
Frank's way right there close your head
go
[Applause]
up to red light there he says I got this
[Applause]
holder wants to keep it I was scared to
freaking move dude it Wow big statement
that round big statement all the
momentum is on digit right now well I
was scared to drive back home this is
for a hammer and he or laying it yeah
this was a great round Harvey J just
secured the better position on top of
Craig's hand and arm and rotated through
for the pin look at him drag his elbow
back exposing Craig on to his bicep and
letting Rob use pronation and back
pressure and side pressure really a
multitude of angles to get the pin Wow
so two one for Rob hitch and junior
against Craig - yay
in this middleweight title bow 40
seconds left to go between poles Harvey
J wins one more - yay trying to extend
it a little bit longer to see if he can
keep his hopes of grabbing a hammer a
while Rob is in the driver's seat right
here he knows he's got what it takes to
win this match he's got the momentum in
the confidence I think he's gonna close
the door here talk to him warrior huge
stout believe says he feels confident
chasing this hammer this is my shot to
make this go to a decisive right there
it's going to the straps would you
expect anything else the way these two
have gone now I was fighting for every
little sliver of position getting that
grip and now they'll go to the strap how
it's look and how dominant Rob's hand is
starting to be Craig's wrist is starting
to give more and more put it where you
want and he's really going to need to
get into position early because if Rob
stops them I think it's over
bitchin Junior said what you're on top
you feel that pressure just prove to
everybody you didn't lock your way into
the title this to keep the hammer
we're supposed to be calmed along the
wall right here right there can you
tighten it up a little bit it's loose
pose your thumb right here close your
head
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
and impressive
[Applause]
look at that yeah the cabbage a flex it
off and the hammer as we look again at
him closing it out yeah our Vijay just
he stopped them
Craig kept surging he could have
finished and Rob just got a little bit
better positioning and was able to get
the win and keep the hammer and again
finished last season strong starts off
this season on fire taking out Craig -
yay he came in as hall but could not
overcome that prime power from Rob
pigeon - final few centimeters to get
his man down and does and then and then
it's time to flex after a big win what
else would you do our Vijay flexing and
showcasing and right now Jason Fisher is
standing by with Craig - yay Craig seems
like he had trouble getting comfortable
at the start of the match trying to find
the right grip going into the strap see
your assessment what happened here
tonight well a couple of times you know
if Rob felt Aloha that was trying to
make him come down he's got an extremely
big hand I got to give it to him is
because he worked everything tonight -
is the best and it worked now you've
taken on our DJ before and you win him
pretty convincing fashion what was the
difference between the rvj then and you
faced here tonight oh he was very
focused and he felt amazing he did an
awesome year last year I'm very proud of
him and he's going to keep going well
same for you as well everyone let's give
it up one time for Craig Tooley a can't
wait to see your next
well let's give it up for our winner
right here
our Vijay come on over my man all right
had to get that shirt off huh
it needs a go it was Spartan time well
you are clearly on a roll right now
I just asked Greg you were defeated by
him pretty handily the last time that
you faced him what is the difference
with this rvj versus who he faced the
last time I trained for him
and I came prepared preparation is a
beautiful thing in this sport you'll be
a victim if you're not well how long can
you keep this streak going now you're
defending the hammer it's still in your
possession
how long will this last I'm at the top
of the mountain but over the winter I
planted a tree an oak and that [ __ ]
grew roots I'm here to stay all right
well you are a tree is there anyone you
want next in particular or just bring it
on no just line them up no problems all
right well hey let's bring out that
hammer it is still in your possession
everyone rvj give it up for your
defending champion right here
[Applause]
[Music]
there it is congratulations Jason max
back to you guys
Jason rvj thank you very much said he
planted an oak trees got a couple
attached to his shoulders there and
showcased them and fine displays our
Vijay defends the middleweight title Wow
what a match it actually did live up to
the height I knew I knew that one was
gonna be a grinder and the both guys
came prepared and they're both
aggressive they played their game Rob
had the better game plan into a trying
to get those quick finishes but not able
as she talked about Rob caught it a
couple of times and looked like he just
warmed down yeah our BJ's in shape and I
asked him is this your prime and he's
like I think it's just the start of my
prime he's like I don't even think I've
reached my full potential yet yeah he
talked to as a Massachusetts guy New
England guy about Tom Brady just kind of
get in there yeah fitting maybe he's
talking about the Pats quarterback for a
Boston area guys see if he can keep this
rolling along we'll see but the first
title defense goes in his favor how
about two big time name's Todd Zilla no
limits Devin Lehren todd Hutchings they
are ready to go right way and no limits
it's gonna be fun this is gonna be a
show Devin never disappoints and Todd
Silla is just a powerhouse this guy is
pound for pound
when the freakiest strongest arm
wrestlers of all time this is going to
be a really great matchup Hutchings
Lehren
Todd Zilla no limits there's no stopping
it
there's no more waiting it's coming up
in just a moment
here at stage AE in Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania crowd has enjoyed some
sensational action here tonight will
armwrestling lead wal money girls taken
selfies with the fans and Jason Fischer
is hanging out with an interested
observer and an international observer
isn't that right Jason that's right I'm
here with Ryan Bowen now Ryan you are
the Australian middleweight armwrestling
champion who also hosts a very
successful and popular podcast about
armwrestling you traveled a long way to
be here tonight
what brought you halfway around the
world to be here in Pittsburgh for wal
501 honestly it is this next match
that's coming up this match Devin Lyon
Todd Hutchings this match has the
potential to be one of the greatest of
all time none of these guys when matches
stop typically they don't lose so one of
them is gonna have to tonight and I just
can't wait to see it I would happily do
this again to come and see this match if
you were making a prediction on that
match who do you think is gonna win this
match is normally this is Devin large
match to lose but to be honest he plays
with fire and if he does Todd Hutchins
is the kind of man that could take it
down but it's Devin likes to lose money
all right well you know your stuff I
can't wait to see this final match it's
gonna be good it'll be worth that trip
from Australia it's amazing this whole
event is amazing so good luck to
everyone all right thank you so much
Jason back to you cheers - Ryan glad to
have him along all the way from down
under - check out the action hope you're
enjoying it wherever you're watching
here Jason - max we already second half
of this main event he talked about it
may be one of the best matches of all
time these are two legends I mean you're
talking about Todd Hutchins being one of
the best middleweights of all time and
Devin one being one of the best
heavyweights of all time now they're
meaning to see who's the best of the
best and again they're essentially it's
super heavyweight status here as we look
at the tale of the tape
both of them we talked to them today
they're heavier than they've ever been
yes Todd Hutchings is at 2:45 he's
competed the 195 class for the last few
years so he's all 50 pounds bigger than
his previous weight class Devin 40
pounds bigger they came in hit me
Todd ill as she talked about one of the
best middle weights of all time bumping
it up certainly his strength is
unmatched maybe at his weight class to
get a fair against Lehren pumped up
look let me break it down this way Devin
I think is technically one of the best
if not the best of all time but when
you're talking raw horsepower and side
pressure you can make the argument that
Todd Hutchings is the best at that an
attribute of all time in armwrestling
certainly when he gets into difficult
positions he can make magic happen there
is no quit in him and certainly there
isn't either in no limits again the big
man six-five from Canada can he wear out
his opponent tonight that's his game
that's what he's gonna try to do but the
scary part is they both have the same
game plan their endurance freaks
typically when the match stops just like
my buddy Ryan Bowen said they went but
now who's gonna win when this match
stops between them it's gonna be
exciting to find out we'll see if one of
the other maybe alters their strategy
and goes against what has gotten them so
many accolades and wins in their careers
to beat the ultimate opponent a lot it's
looking like mirror images of beat
themselves and I talked to death before
the match I'm like are you gonna test
them are you gonna go into his you know
his game the inside the deep inside and
deaf
I might have to I might have to so I'm
excited to see if that happens because
Todd much eats I mean the powers of nine
for but it should be a ten there
pound-for-pound Todd sillas power is
maybe arguably the greatest ever well we
cannot wait to see what transpires as
these two get it rolling in a moment a
little while ago we caught up with Devan
No Limits Lehren his thoughts on tonight
life is always nice and easy when you're
winning and I was on a pretty good
streak losing really does hurt and when
you hurt you get uncomfortable and you
fight hard to make your life comfortable
again and the way you get comfortable in
this sport is by getting strong and I
took all winter to try and accomplish
that so I'm here season opener and I'm
stronger than I've ever been so let's do
this let's do it indeed again he lost a
Michael Todd last September to end the
year huge offseason training spent a
bunch of time in Europe and a lot of
match training in Australia and Malaysia
to try to get ready for this we'll see
if he Israel yeah I mean you heard of
he's confident he's confident and I
think you do learn more from your losses
than you do your wins and that's what
really pushes you to be better
well we can't wait to see how things go
on but before we do how about a little
bit more about the story of the man they
call Todd Zilla Hyde Hudgens I'm 195
pounds been armwrestling since 2000 I'm
a mechanical engineer designing vacuum
trucks and hydro excavation equipment
from the current WL champion for the
hundred ninety five class both right and
left I'm the only WL champion that's won
both classes there's people that are
close to my power level but they're few
and far between and I got best-in-class
dream a fair start nobody can touch me
we're going to the National Forest about
three miles from my house in order to
develop work capacity I need a very
large isolated area I have one cardio
technique only one person in the world
can do it and I swing those hammers for
an hour walking down the gravel road
training is probably more important than
practice especially at my age in my
experience level I train once a month
now with sparring that kind of stuff
we're currently living in Marietta Ohio
this is the first sparring session we've
had since we moved here my wife Allie
pulls 15 here I just put up board that I
needed people to practice with and a lot
of them came today it's been a good
practice session does give me a chance
to offer some coaching tips and advice
to some of the beginners right
what you want is your hand forwards the
hardy squeeze your fingers your wrist
tends to go backwards right if your
fingers are relaxed you get more on the
back of my hand
so now you're not rolling out right and
you're not so much going backwards to me
it doesn't really matter what you're the
best in the world but if you can sit
back at the end of a day even if it only
lasts for a day and say hey I'm the best
in the world at this on this particular
day that is satisfying that's one of the
most satisfying things I've done
Todd Silla open a post another big win
tonight as we get ready to go time for
the introductions of this one let's get
you to Ian
Ricca body it is now time for this heavy
weight contest will be best-of-five bull
introducing first here's an inside
puller who was one to wal middleweight
hammers sitting at 5 feet 10 inches tall
weighing in at 245 pounds tonight he
steps up in weight class putting his
amazing
35 in 3 records to the test he was an
international star from Ohio he
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and introducing his opponent he is a six
foot five nightmare weighing in tonight
at 266 pounds with a 32 and 4 record he
is one of the most decorated arm
wrestlers on the planet from 2014 to
2017 he raised the heavyweight hammer
high from Ottawa Canada he use his quest
for the hammer in 2019 tonight here in
Pittsburgh he is
yeah here we go new limits reading
against Godzilla says I have a lot of
respect for him he's dangerous he's very
strong he's unrelenting and he's also
willing to die out therapy faster Todd's
just got that type of mentality that it
doesn't matter where the match goes it
doesn't matter the angle oh he's just
gonna run and drive to the side okay a
lot to stop so the five grand on the
table for the W money girl
these two get down to biz follow the
commands of the rough ticket starting to
my ankle webbing first starts tearing
down the intensity that size big
difference shorter man come and take his
hand and take it down arm away from go
this way come down
if you don't follow the coming of the
Devon told us if I can bend his wrist
back puts me in the driver's seat but
he's still really good right now when I
give a command back whoever does Bart
wood is surveying his territory here
with Merritt and Hutchings who shout out
yeah they they know the rules and they
like to exploit the rules especially
Devon but hey you ain't cheatin a tried
9 tell me al titles in his career both
left and right-handed
they've never pulled right-handed before
Devon said they thinks they did once
left-handed yeah and that makes us mad
dangerous because they haven't felt each
other's power and they really don't know
the real full force that's about to be
put on to their arms and I can't wait to
see this bathroom bring their floor the
magic back though cause wait right there
close your phone
those were here
[Applause]
it's a
[Applause]
this is a position
[Applause]
can't
Devon's taking his hand this is
dangerous guitar damage stretching him
out
how the wrong time keeper
time running back
knows it where you Devin wins Lehren
takes your boy quit your boy quit round
one Bob he's in Todd's corner tying him
that he'd quit never touch his corner I
thought that that was a pimp that was I
want to see the replay I want to see
this replay because Paul its initial
surge might have been a pain but it was
so let's take a look right here now this
is the end of the match with Devin took
control and Todd you knew it was over
there yep but that initial surge off the
start was what I what I meant by that
was possibly a pin very very close it's
funny huh cheese power so doc came in he
talked to Devin Laird said a lot of
folks saying look you got to try to get
him quick and Devin you know he loves
the back look at the start here
Todd surges surges are so close
did it break the plane there Jason oh
[Music]
it's baby half an inch it can maybe a
centimeter or two there oh that's close
no complaint from Hutchings he didn't
come back and sit there and say come
down round one the best time to Devon
there come Devon's way closer to the top
he's flying
close your hands look found right here
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay square up all the palm webbing
equals back to the strap yeah 30 seconds
they couldn't get the grip and the crowd
is really into this one a lot of a lot
of energy coming from the crowd for both
guys good example did I get a double
damage usually I'd say yeah but which
guy in this case hard to say both of
their power comes where up
Devon more technical in it Todd just
able to really put the horsepower down
using it we mentioned close to 45
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Devon sets him in a deep hole
[Applause]
Hutchings looking for every
[Applause]
he thinks his tavern
[Applause]
[Music]
Tom's not human look at that in any
other man with this leverage in this
position you would easily finish your
poem
[Applause]
you saw the transition daily lever
[Music]
the table no two of the best endurance
coolers ever and you're seeing it each
and every look at the replay here taught
way out of position loses hand and wrist
and Devon just takes full advantage of
that climbing higher gaining more
leverage using his height look at that
that's just tremendous leverage and he's
able to back it up with his tricep and
press for the win look at the close-up
here yeah
using his shoulder and his tricep and
using his body weight to press down on
Todd's arm talking about their kids back
home in Canada when Chile also polar
also competes absolutely part wrestling
family I think the kids actually compete
as well so you're really talking to a
bloodline there no limits to what that
family can do right now to heaven Lara
in control here taking the first two one
away from squeaking top notches and
definitely looking impressive
she said hit she wants to see Devon fit
all right he's in Tahoe which tonzilla
need to do here to stay alive and rattle
off a couple of wins in the world this
is tough for Todd deep water here and
his arms Bernie now I know his arms
filling with blood from those two tough
rounds he's in deep water if that one's
looking to sing from fun and
ridiculously strong freak of nature for
the top weight of all time here weight
against no limits Larry no
[Applause]
[Music]
yep gives the money to the white party
tonight buddy Jody's got the cash
Devon's got the win in the end
Hutchings knew it went round three there
but Todd's art was birth look at that
cause arm just two rounds of brutal
abuse by Devin and Devin just took
control and ended them look at that
reaction from Japanese hi I love it
Todd Hutchings at a bigger weight he's
ever been before but no limits gets the
win Todd standing by with Jason Fisher
Todd their middleweight champion this is
your first match here as a heavyweight
what is it like hoeing in this new
weight class against guys like Devin
Larry it sucks
I recommend winning all the time the
other side just sucks well you
definitely pulled hard you definitely
tested Devin layer it for sure you have
a tough match coming up next month in
Baltimore against Matt mask how do you
take what you learned here tonight and
apply it and prepare for your next match
well I'm gonna get taller other these
six - next time and I know you very well
I just run out a table so hey no one is
stronger than this man right here
everyone let's give it up one time for
Todd Zilla
Todd Wachtel
and let's give it up one time for Devon
literate Devon first tell me a little
bit about what it's like to pay someone
like Todd Hutchins Todd Hutchins is so
good that they kicked them out of the
category okay Tata Chang's is the very
best middleweight we got okay
he's overachieving in the super
heavyweight category but I do have bad
news for you
my little brother's gonna do the same
thing only worse see in a month but and
that and that's true that's true
but I just hope that he does get a shot
to reclaim what might be his and rvj in
the finals that's what I'd love to see
okay okay well speaking to someone who
wants to reclaim what might be theirs
this is the first time we saw you on a
wal stage since losing to monster
Michael Todd how big is this match in
this win in your quest to reclaim the
hammer its it's big for me I'm happy
that I get to do the Icebreaker for the
season I feel like that sets me up you
know these guys got matches coming up
that whole while I'm gonna be training
them so I'm gonna be better prepared
than they are so try and get through the
next round safe because I'm gonna be
fresh when I see you okay well you heard
it
Devon larren he is training he is
getting stronger that is a scary thought
this is gonna be a great season this was
a great night Congrats Devon
Jason max back to you guys Jason Devon
Todd thanks what a show
they're by no limits and Todd Zilla
Jason to max back here what a night
captain with that pal rbj defends the
hammer compelling women's thatch this
night had it all it built up and it
built up and I think I think it lived up
to the expectations especially with
those first couple rounds and just
all-out just grinder and I love that I
love seeing it go deep and Devin testing
Todd in his full power and feeling it
and he in the six foot five Devan Lera
table to get it done over Todd Hutchings
to cap the night here from stage AE in
Pittsburgh been awesome and continue to
see more the action throughout the
season here including on Bleacher Report
catch all the world armwrestling league
action on be our live download the BR
live app on your mobile device Apple TV
Roku and Amazon fire TV and the next
match coming up with the elite
superstars the wal Superman showdown
series wao 502 Baltimore May 16th
live from Rams head live in downtown
Baltimore Maryland have a Jeff Hale Sam
Harris and as you heard Tata cheese back
at it against Mad Max those should be a
couple of good headless gave me a great
event has we're seeing replays from some
of the
tonight awesome way to kick off the new
season new champion new champions will
rise and old champions will fall and
there's gonna be a lotta so they come
guys stay tuned we ain't done yet
well that's it from wao 501 Pittsburgh
thanks to executive producers Warren Vic
and Ed Warren technical director Greg
Rita camp senior producer J Cabrera
president commissioner the wao Steve
Kaplan and our buddy Penn Holden who
normally sits in this chair
get well soon Ben meet you back here
soon for max Tobin and the rest of our
crew Jason M saying so long see you next
month
Ciara some more yeah